[موسيقى]
أجرينا هذا البحث لأننا نعتقد أن
الرؤية ليست كافية ، فنحن نحب أن
نكمل ما
نراه بآذاننا والجهاز المذهل
في دماغنا الذي يعالج
المعلومات المسموعة لاكتساب
رؤى إضافية حول كيفية تشكل الهياكل
[الموسيقى]
التي صنعناها  عالم الواقع
لأننا نحب استكشاف شبكة
العنكبوت بالطريقة التي سيختبرها بها العنكبوت
ولكن بالطبع البشر أكبر من أن
لا نلائم شبكة العنكبوت ، لذلك
نضع أنفسنا أساسًا في نموذج كمبيوتر
لاستكشاف النظام
باستخدام الواقع الافتراضي
تستخدم العناكب الاهتزازات كطريقة للتواصل
مع بعضها البعض ومع العالم من
حولها ، لذلك من خلال تسجيل هذه
الاهتزازات واستخدام
خوارزميات الذكاء الاصطناعي لتكرارها
لتصنيفها أو توليفها
من نقطة الصفر ،
سنتمكن من ذلك  التحدث
مع العناكب والتواصل مع
العناكب وربما إثارة ردود أفعال
منهم والقدرة على التحدث معهم وإجراء محادثة قصيرة معهم.